hi I'm Timmy the trashcan and I love
trash they all taste so good instead of
throwing your trash on the floor won't
you please give it to me thank you for
considering your fellow patrons thank
you to all the people on Instagram that
have reached out to me that are gay but
also Nazis that are very excited that
there is a gay guy out there that
doesn't make being gay his whole thing
and it's real fun some of those messages
I get people are like listen hey I just
want to let you know I'm a gay guy I'm
also a Nazi and I just want to reach out
because it's very important that well
I'm kidding of course but you do get a
lot of messages from a lot of different
people out there you don't know who they
are you don't know who's a [ __ ] Fed
there's some feds in my inbox probably I
don't know keeping tabs on me maybe not
some dude who looks like a [ __ ] the
hot lacrosse player but it's really a 58
year old and [ __ ] Virginia in an FBI
office just [ __ ] trying to figure out
the inner workings of my mind so they
can co-op me and weaponize me the
irishman zoo is a real movie finally a
real movie i love the the best facebook
status I read about the Irishmen as a
guy be like you're not going to get it
if you're not from certain parts of
Peace Coast Jersey New York Philly
that's what people don't like it they're
not from these parts yeah the guy who
spent his life working at blockbuster
he identifies with the Irishman the
movie about Hoffa a lot of strong
opinions out there in the world we're in
the month of December folks December is
such a as my boomer father would say
good man as he would say it's so fast it
all goes by so fast which it does when
you're destroying the world it tends to
it's it's uh it accelerates when you're
using up all of the resources yeah
it just goes so fast that's all my dad
would say at holiday parties you know
he'd go where does the time go where
does it go you know it goes to mortgage
crisis is and it goes to trillions of
dollars worth of debt you know that's
where it goes it is a fun month I'm
traveling a lot I'm going to the East
Coast a lot try to link up with people
somebody did this to me the other day
which I don't love they do the the
dinner sneak where they go hey you want
to do dinner and I go yeah and they go
oh great
so and so is gonna come and I'm like no
no they're not gonna come you don't do
that you you don't ever DM somebody or
text somebody and go hey let you want to
go to dinner because that's a solo
invite to people dinner is different
than dinner with me and and and somebody
else it's a different game when you
bring somebody else to the dinner three
people dynamic unless you all know each
other well the dynamic changes so you
got to be up front and go hey would you
like to do dinner with me and blank not
hey you want to do dinner I'm under the
impression it's just with you and then
you bring in a demon from Hell and then
I have to sit there and eat Caesar salad
with you know
I don't know but it's not right be
upfront these two cats are fighting
again man they always [ __ ] fight I
don't know what it is there's a lot of
hostility these are not my cats I'm
living in a home in Los Angeles where
the woman that I rent from has abandoned
the home she has gone to New York to
live which is fine I'm renting it's a
good deal it's by the comedy clubs it's
right in the in central you know LA in a
nice area I don't want to tell you
really where it is because [ __ ] I
don't need people knocking on my door
trying to tell me about queueing on okay
well I'm waiting for post mates but what
they've done is they've left the two
cats here and they all they talk about
is how much they love the cats they love
the animals but they've abandoned them
they've abandoned the animals that they
supposedly love and and her and her
daughter I mean they all you know when
you bring up they think uh-oh is the cat
okay
it's the cattle kit we'll come see it or
take it get it out of here and when that
one of the cats dies which will happen
they're gonna be there's gonna be crying
and people are gonna be upset but it's
like if you care about the animals be
here for the animals
we've overdosed in this country on
animals dogs and cats if you are young
and you're in your 20s and you want to
accomplish anything which most of you
don't but if you truly do you should not
have dogs or cats I'm telling you right
now and this is gonna be unpopular with
a lot of you because a lot of you stop
fighting a lot of you I don't know what
they're fighting over resources there's
enough here to get it they like
territorial over the litter box cats are
so disgusting the litter box always
smells like [ __ ] cat food smells bad
cats are filthy creatures they're
they're like mops you know they just
soak up all the dirt and the dust things
live on them fleas and ticks and god
only knows there's a whole [ __ ]
ecosystem living on these
East's and dogs are not much better
folks they're not much better and I know
a lot of you are gonna get angry right
now because you don't want to hear this
you don't want to hear this this is Tim
Dylan's holiday message are you ready
for it
because I don't shy away from
controversy I call cashew von the
patreon
he's the Parkland kid that wants more
guns and he says the n-word and he lets
it fly on Xbox Live and he I had him in
my home and I bought him sushi and that
ungrateful [ __ ] didn't say thank you and
I should have opened some hot lead into
his abdomen and see how he liked it
because I spent $100 on a sushi platter
and I got three pints of ice cream from
salt & straw which was another 50
[ __ ] dollars where your patreon money
goes is feeding this [ __ ] Jew and
furthermore he comes into the house he
shits on been for vaping been does vape
a lot but he's made a lot of positive
changes in his life
and he doesn't need to hear [ __ ] from
this little kid okay who's famous
because he accidentally didn't get
killed and so we have he's yelling at
Ben for vaping and poor Ben gets really
mad Abed never gets mad at anybody but
Ben's like hey man you know I used to
smoke cigarettes and drink and now I
just vape but it's like Ben don't let
this little prick get under your skin
Ben can you get the I think that's the
pokeball is here that's not a euphemism
for crack that's a literal pokeball you
sit it on the table I'll get to it later
the key to the pokeball folks is a
sriracha ponzu you got a the Sri Racha
this what is it sriracha it's not Sri
Racha right
it's sriracha yeah that's the move but
anyway so cashews gets here and we also
have CM Triple E for an hour you know
talking about Q and on and frazzled trip
and you know talking about the Hillary
Clinton kid cookbook so that'll be out
too you're missing a lot why not I'm
really given a [ __ ] I'm really giving
a great unsubscribe from the patreon
pitch right here so khushu gets here he
starts then he starts [ __ ] on Oscar
because Oscars fat and everyone knows
Oscar from Instagram he's too fat cat
I'm like number one
Oscar if you shave them is not that fat
he's not morbidly obese he's a fat cat
cuz cats are supposed to be fat and then
cashews like no animals aren't supposed
to be fat it's not natural I'm like what
about elephants bears whales pant
there's a lot of [ __ ] animals it
should be fat cashews you know it all
little prick who's 18 years old doesn't
he doesn't know anything sweet kid but
he was really testing us last night and
he comes in here and he just [ __ ]
starts popping off call me a Boomer cuz
cuz he says I don't text right it's just
out of control no respect no respect
okay so my point folks about the animals
is and this is my and this is what I
mean I don't shy away from controversy
we bring it to you raw uncensored I go
after shoes now somebody's gonna be mad
at me because I asked him I push him on
his narrative because he's like you know
guns guns guns you know we wish you a
Merry Christmas here is an ak-47 and I
know that every time I push back a
little I go wait a minute is there a
better way to do it all of you get mad
cuz you think oh you're a Hollywood show
you're being paid no one's taking your
guns what I'm saying is if anyone comes
on the show and say I'm gonna push back
at what they're saying number one
because it doesn't necessarily make a
good episode to agree with somebody it's
actually not a good episode but many of
you are too insecure in your own beliefs
so all you do is listen to people that
you agree with already because your your
lives are meaningless so you just turn
on whatever garbage that someone will
agree with you already because you just
want to hear that you're right so you
can go back to your loveless home and
choke down a pork chop and then go to
sleep knowing that you're in the right
you're in the right side of history pal
so yeah I do have questions about guns I
do think there's a better way to do it
you should make guns harder to get you
shouldn't take them away but you should
make them harder to do No
they're already hard to get well shut up
they're not as hard as they should be I
think most people would agree with that
most sober rational people would agree
with that
so I push back a little bit of cashew
okay I know that on law and you're all
psychopaths most people are in the
center most people don't care
most people don't wanna you know you
know rehabilitate Stalin or Hitler
that's just not what they do they're
sitting in a cubicle with little
Christmas cards on it they have a family
they're just trying to get by they're
not into you know you know [ __ ] you
know the extremes I talk to people all
the time and it's like some people just
online all day every [ __ ] day take a
walk you know take a walk but we have
cashew Vaughn here and and now that
cashews been here I think everyone
should have a gun and most people should
get shot
I now pro school shootings because I've
interviewed him I want no gun
restrictions I want everybody that wants
a gun to have a gun and I want I want
schools to be shot up randomly so
because these [ __ ] 18 year olds this
kid comes over here just as sushi
doesn't say thank you
there's no thank you anyway the point of
saying about the dogs and cats here's
here's what I'm saying about dogs and
cats for Christmas if you're having a
Christmas event at your house have the
decency to put your dog or cat to sleep
before you have your family there put
them down put them down especially if
you don't have the big home if your home
is not already impressive if it's not
nobody wants to smell the dog or the cat
the mangy put them down put them to
sleep and I know it's a controversial
message put your animals to sleep and
focus on yourself you made a mistake
learn to love yourself get rid of the
dog get rid of the cat they do not love
you they just want food yes they're fun
to have when you have a certain when
you've reached something in life they're
fun to have but when you're
struggling you got to get people to
watcher do you know how many people I
see online that have people watch their
dog can you watch my dog there's a whole
industry of people that bring losers in
to watch their animals kill them put
them down get rid of them it's if you
cannot handle the responsibility of
having an animal get rid of it you are
giving yourself an excuse to be a loser
I can't do it my dog my cat you you've
adopted another person another life-form
that's going to that that is needy just
like yourself you're needy you need
someone to come and feed you you need
someone to come and walk you now you've
adopted another loser like yourself who
needs constant attention and then you
try to pawn it off on other people
because you can't afford a that's one
thing if you have a professional command
that's a different game but if you're
just pawning your animals off on your
friends and family because and or your
children on your friends and family you
should put them to sleep your animals
and your children put them to sleep
smother them smother your children if
you cannot of if you had a child and
it's two or three years old and you just
it's too much pressure smother them in
their sleep this is I just sometimes I
say lines like that because I think it'd
be a very funny place to put an ad like
right after right after smother your
children in their sleep I I could start
talking about Ridge wallet I just think
that's a funny I'm not serious about
smothering your children I'm not serious
about killing your children I'm really
not even serious about putting your
animals down what I'm saying is I'm
making a I'm making it point in a funny
whay my point is that far too many
people have pets it's gotten out of
control
far too many people make their pets
their identity it's very sad and it's
very disgusting and we all see that
you're doing it and listen I put
pictures of Oscar up online all the time
because he's funny okay because he's
been deep platformed he lost her social
media account for publishing nancy
pelosi's address he's been accused of
trying to violently overthrow the
government he's been kicked off a lot of
crowdfunding sites so when I platform
him it's because he lacks a platform but
enough with them enough with the animals
all the time you know what I'm saying
folks use your own judgment but what I'm
saying is you just have to you know
enough already my aunt my father and his
wife bring their dog everywhere my
father and his wife have three dogs you
want to hear about these dogs I'm gonna
tell you about these dogs okay but my
father is married to a lovely woman
she's very liberal which is great her
parents are very liberal but they're
lovely people and I enjoy them okay how
liberal is she here are the names of the
dogs Fred for Frederick Douglass by the
way my father his wife are white just in
case you were wondering white like I'm
white blotchy red Irish white pale
translucent burning skin cooks like a
Red Lobster in the Sun white white okay
white bars suburban white she might be a
little Cuban whatever Fred for Frederick
Douglass what's the other dog's name
Maya for Maya Angelou my is a lily-white
dog my is a white dog looks like a white
supremacist the third dog is named hold
on Ruth for Ruth Bader Ginsburg Ruth
Bader Ginsburg my Angelou and Frederick
Douglass are their three dogs that they
have
they brought them to my grandmother's
house one year and my uncle Tommy who is
like a drunken lunatic but I do like
because I appreciate that in a person he
doesn't make America great again had and
he's great he's just a fun he's just a
fun guy you know he kind of lets it fly
when he's doing the barbecue you know I
think he had some business deal didn't
go well with Jews once and he's like
maybe little Herschel can't go to summer
camp this year he's like flipping
burgers I enjoy that you know I like
when people lean in you know I he came
up to me once he's like you're
lifestyles no problem with me I'm like
well thanks so much thanks for calling
it a lifestyle I appreciate it I should
I go die of AIDS now in the kitchen
floor
just to make you know so he's nuts I
mean he's a crazy print but but I
appreciate that he's I like like him I
like him better than the liberal people
like I rather him you know this is why
Trump gets elected because you'd rather
the crate like Kamala Harris drops out
today and all these people or they're
throwing a fit it's like knuckle it down
get ready for the fight stop tearing
each other apart you want diversity I'll
support Cynthia McKinney
do you know Cynthia McKinney is she's
the black four term congresswoman from
Georgia who punched a [ __ ] cop on
Capitol Hill and questions 911 all the
time I'll support her phone bank for
Cynthia hi this is Tim Dylan have you
heard about Cynthia McKinney she just
started to she just wandered into the
Gaza Strip and she started going crazy
one that I support her bring her in pull
the lever for synth but so they got
these three dogs they bring them to my
grandmother's house for her birthday
my uncle Tommy like loses his mind he's
had a few drinks he's like you know you
know my mother hates dogs here [ __ ]
selfish you're a selfish like and by the
way he's a hundred percent in the right
leave the animals home don't travel with
nobody wants your animals in their house
tommy's may be wrong about a lot of
things race relations gender dynamics
you know you know who who you shouldn't
shouldn't support in World War two I
don't know but he was right about that
get your [ __ ] dogs out of the house
too much with my dad we'll just text me
a photo of his dog he's like Hello Fred
says hello
it's Ann I get it because the kids are
raised the kids are raised and there's
nothing really to love except boomers
didn't really love the kids that much
anyway the boom she booms the boomers
really weren't that into the kids the
boomers would bring the kids to do
things they wanted to do that's why me
and my generation saw like movies we
shouldn't have seen when we were like 5
because our parents wanted to go so they
would just seat us in the theater next
to them while they saw Basic Instinct
while Sharon Stone's getting plowed and
your [ __ ] 9 but it is what it is
because your parents weren't gonna get a
babysitter for you because it was about
them and now the dogs and this is why so
many boomers love their animal and I'm
not hating on you listen I love animals
everybody loves animals I'm just saying
it's a little too much you know what I
mean we all know what I mean now there's
people walking around New York City
pushing strollers with dogs in them it's
[ __ ] insane it is crazy and and for
whatever reason the boomers have gotten
really into animals
the boomers have really gotten into like
dogs little dogs and cats and they're
very in they're more into that than they
were ever into being parents so it's
very interesting to watch that happen
because they're a little older now and
they're like and they they you know they
love doting on an animal I'm just saying
as the holidays come up and you're
asking people to go to your homes just
keep in mind that not everybody's in
love everybody loves a dog that's clean
and well captain ok and a cat is fun but
let's not let's not have a barn when you
walk in a house you know what I mean
house that I'm staying at sometimes when
you walk in it's you like walking into a
barn when I first got here there were
multiple dogs multiple cats and you'd be
walking in and you hear when you're at
somebody's door
I [ __ ] cringe when I'm at somebody's
door and I hear the [ __ ] panting and
the [ __ ] already already I hear the
the collars jingling and the panting and
the barking and screaming because I know
I'm gonna walk into a pigsty I'm gonna
walk into a pigsty I'm going to walk
into a barn and I'm going to walk into a
disgusting home that smells like a wet
dog or it smells like cat piss it smells
like a cat just took a piss all over the
house and I know people love their
animals I'm not gonna keep doing that
disclaimer I'm doing it one more time
because I love animals I don't hate
animals but I think people need to
realize that you need to to [ __ ] keep
up with you you D animals can't run the
house you know far too many people you
go into their homes the animals run the
house you sit on the couch as five dogs
have jumped on you and start drooling
biting [ __ ] you my friend just got a
dog and you know everything's about his
dog now which is great he loves his dog
and he's you know buddy doesn't have
time he sees dog that much but you know
he loves his dog it helps him learn
responsibility which is good and and
that's I I appreciate that I respect
that
you know I'm just you know I'm gonna
wrap it up with the animal chunk I'm
just saying you know somebody's house
here today knocking on a door you
waiting to walk into their home and
you're just basically bracing yourself
for everything you own to be ruined
you're bracing yourself for spit and
[ __ ] hair just dog hair and cat hair
and then you're just brushing it off
yourself
in an uber just clumps of hair and then
wherever you're going you're walking to
a meeting you're walking in somewhere
else you've got a it looks like you have
pubic hair all over your body manscaped
there'll be a great man's cape placement
that's why you got mom's script office
Christmas parties are coming up folks
office Christmas parties maybe some of
you are throwing them office Christmas
parties were a lot of fun not as much
for sober people they're just not many
of you were sober I'm sober things are
less fun for us now own that understand
that stop living in a fantasy world that
things are as fun as they used to be but
things are not as fun as they used to be
but they're also not as bad as they used
to be there is the trade-off and when
you're an adult you understand that
that's what it is
life is a trade-off it is not as fun to
go to a Christmas party sober in fact
it's almost pointless not completely
pointless but it's almost pointless
because alcohol is that social lubricant
that allows you to really first of all
what alcohol allows you to do at
Christmas parties is you start looking
around at the people that you see every
day and you start appreciating them and
you start imagining that what's going on
constitutes a life which it doesn't at
all but alcohol allows you to believe
that sue from accounting and you are
have a bond because that one time she
got your name wrong but then she rushed
a change so that you could get paid by
Friday and remember that sue remember
that and remember when you came in the
kitchen and I was like eyeballing
Talia's lunch and you made that joke oh
don't steal her lunch and I didn't and
you know but you always kind of looked
at me skeptically sue because of that
and you thought maybe he was stealing
lunches and I wasn't what I was doing
this is a hypothetical what I was doing
is I was looking at what other people
ate that's what I was doing I wasn't
stealing
anything but you need to why don't you
go back to your office and [ __ ] get
the names on the checks right because
I've worked here for seven months ooh so
what alcohol allows you to do is when
you get really hammered you don't want
you to die in a car accident anymore
which is what you want every day you
want to say hello to sue you want to say
how are you how's your daughter
you have a daughter oh she's and she's
going to Northwestern isn't that good
sue great yeah and then you make some
dumb joke and that's what it allows you
to do you look around at the people in
your orbit and you go oh these are
people and this is a life I'm living a
life this is a life this will do this
will do it's Christmas I work at a
shitty company we all hate each other
world terrified of losing our job we're
working for this [ __ ] trunk loser
this whole thing's probably a Ponzi
scheme we're probably gonna be thrown
out into the street any minute but right
now there are lights on the bar there's
booze in my cup there's a Southwestern
eggroll if you're lucky enough to be a
Chili's if you're lucky enough to be at
Chili's
there's a Southwestern egg roll or
there's a little shrimp with a tangy
[ __ ] you know cocktail sauce or you
know what do they love in Long Island
that bang bang shrimp that fried shrimp
with that chipotle aioli [ __ ] fires
cracker sauce well you know exactly what
I'm talking about and you can nibble on
that and booze it up while bald Mike
from accounting comes over and tells a
couple of street jokes that he heard and
if you have to do that sober you want to
shoot up the whole thing it's hard to do
it doesn't make any sense because you
realize very quickly if you're sober
that this is a horror of all the places
in my life I could have ended up to end
up in this shitty bar in a strip mall
with these losers in this corner of the
world is such a human tragedy sure it's
not as bad
he's stepping on a landmine or having
cancer or getting [ __ ] every day by
Senators and that or having a [ __ ]
you know an adoption go wrong and then
you didn't burn with cigarettes I get it
people have worse problems but if you're
a sentient human being in yourself aware
and you look around and you have to [ __ ]
and have another conversation with Denis
Denis who talks only about the one time
she went to Aruba and that she's saving
up for another cruise so she can take
her plump fat Italian ass and put it on
the top deck of a carnival ship so she
can tan and when I fan I'm basically
black I'm basically black when I did I
did I'm black I'm black when I Dan and
you have to sit there and you have to
listen to these people these
mouth-breathers they don't have any idea
that they two are locked in this hell
that they are in this [ __ ] simulation
but they are not cursed with
self-awareness like you are they are
like animals they don't have the power
of reason they don't think they just
fart and [ __ ] and move and the pedal to
the metal and then they stop the car and
start the car open the door close the
door take a [ __ ] I'm hungry I'm not
hungry
cocaine nostril boom that's what they do
but you for whatever reason have been
cursed like much of humanity with a
little self-awareness so when you're at
that bar and maybe you're a little early
and you're waiting in your car because
you don't want to be the first one there
but you're not gonna go home first cuz
if you go home first you know you're not
gonna [ __ ] go you know you're not
going if you go home first you get to
the place a little [ __ ] early because
god forbid you work a little harder at
work so you get there a little early and
you're just in the bar and you get there
and you're alone and the only person
who's there is [ __ ] Ralph and Ralph's
creepy as [ __ ] and he's probably a
pedophile you don't know but he's
[ __ ] weird because he talks about
high school girls a lot and that makes
you very uncomfortable and Ralph is
there and you're like [ __ ] I don't want
people walking in and seeing me and
Ralph's there but who walks in the ball
and he walked in cuz you're standing
there would [ __ ] Ralph and you're
like [ __ ] and the boss is there just to
make sure everything goes well tonight
you know because he knows he's running a
scam but at least he's got to keep
everyone invested in it once a year
he throws a stupid shitty Christmas
party we got a tray of wings a chafing
dish of you know balsamic chicken sub
penne alla vodka and you walk around you
commiserate with these [ __ ] dolts
that you work with and you have to see
every day and at that point some booze
and a few hits off a [ __ ] blunt or
vape can really go a long way a nice
cold cigarette when you're all lubed up
with some kettle one can really help a
holiday party just sail by it almost
might be fun it starts to get fun
because you start to realize it's not
that bad things aren't that bad things
aren't that bad look where other people
are that kid you grew up with he's dead
remember him no one he just disappeared
one day and they found him in a lake
what happened to him in those final
hours you'll never know but you're in
Long Island it's okay there's movie
theaters and Italian restaurants and
girls that might suck your dick if you
buy an eggplant parmesan things aren't
that bad and sure you didn't really do
anything with your life and you're just
floating around you're 25 years old
you're sexually weird and confused you
can barely perform with women you don't
have that many friends left many of them
have passed you by and they threaten you
so you get them out you know and it's
fine though because at the end of the
day these people at this shitty job see
promising you I mean do they really
let's be honest they hired you before
you even said anything they just needed
a warm body in their office to convince
themselves what they were doing was
[ __ ] reasonable but hey it doesn't
matter it's not not bad because you can
call that fat girl again you bone last
month maybe she'll be involved and then
you can just [ __ ] not even cuz you enjoy
it just cuz you can say to yourself well
I'm [ __ ] I'm part of it things gonna
happen you can imagine that shitty
little Levitt home you'll buy in a few
years when you just save your money and
your parents are proud of you because
you finally have a basement apartment in
Hicksville with Formica counters
okay so things aren't that bad you're
not in jail you're not in prison you're
not dead
you know it's it's a [ __ ] it's what
you do you measure yourself against the
absolute lowest of the low
you say to yourself hey I'm not shooting
up schools look at me I'm not doing
anything wrong
I'm just here and maybe it's a dead-end
job and maybe I have nothing left and I
have nothing in common with these people
and every passion that I have
I've extinguished because they've all
frightened me but it doesn't matter
because I had a few kettle ones and I
smoked a joint
Ralph's kind of funny now and Denise
she's a big goofball she's saving for a
cruise you know when sheet and she looks
black she's got a big fat ass and you
might [ __ ] that ass who knows it's weird
but then there's another guy in the
office Clark he's kind of gender
nonspecific would you let call Clark
blow you in a bathroom you don't know
that's for the third of the fourth drink
to town and you actually start liking
your boss even though he's clearly a
criminal and he'll probably be in jail
in a few years what he says make sense
about hustling and grinding and just
making it happen he didn't need a
college degree you know he didn't need
you know any discernible talent or skill
he just kept pushing through kept
calling old people and telling them they
should remortgage their house okay and
you just followed that because you
wanted to prove that you're a real man
with Alexis and in those situations it
is so essential so essential to have a
cocktail a stuffed mushroom I mean this
is what am I gonna lie to you I'm not
gonna tell you I'm not gonna tell you
that it's gonna get better not gonna get
better the things that I have to do from
my own business sober after my Netflix
special I went to the Netflix party and
it was embarrassing because Netflix had
like a bucket of hummus that they poured
on the floor and all these poor
comedians got on their hands and knees
and lapped it up like like Street cats
in an alley I was of course appalled by
this and I looked at my manager and I
said I'm leaving and I went with my
friends Eric Taylor and Laura servers
for funny comics from Boston to a local
Waffle House where we witnessed almost a
fight but it was it was
they were the the waffle houses guards
but listen it was late at night and
people were passionate my point is at
Waffle House with two close friends was
much better than a shitty party and many
of the other comedians enjoyed that they
enjoyed hobnobbing with agents and
managers and networks they liked scum
you know they like vapid shells of human
beings they want to walk around and feel
like you're important they want to
really look jury at in that moment to me
I hate it I'm disgusted by it I want to
leave immediately because it's low-rent
[ __ ] its low-rent [ __ ] it's comedy it
should be okay it's not a [ __ ] velvet
rope it's not a [ __ ] VIP section
you're not getting head in the back of
one oak or ten maple it whatever [ __ ]
these places are you're in a shitty
hotel bar with some executive from
Netflix eating hummus it is not an
accomplishment it is an embarrassment
it's another word that sounds like it I
can I can see how you would get them
confused so you run away if you have any
sense I have to go to parties all the
time and I stand there sober and I
realized I don't really enjoy many
people and it's not their fault nor is
it mine it's just the way it is and
booze would help that and weed would
help it and pills would help it but
that's okay it's okay because I realize
that those things also have many many
negative many many negatives and some
people are really do enjoy it and it
makes the person you do connect with
sober all the more meaningful and
important you know maybe whatever the
point is you can't relapse folks you
can't go back you can't go back that's
the point that's what I'm trying to tell
you because you're gonna find a way out
of that life if you sober up if you
[ __ ] have a lot of people [ __ ]
messaging me about drugs and alcohol a
lot of people if you find a way to sober
up yeah yeah you got a few soap you got
a few shitty Christmas parties ahead of
you you're gonna find your way out of
there you're gonna find a way to do
something that you really [ __ ] enjoy
that's what it is survival is not only
about finding food water and shelter
it's about finding something that
doesn't make you miserable to do you'll
find that you know or you'll find a way
to make more money being miserable I
don't know
and then find a hobby you like it's not
my business I'm just saying I'm not
gonna lie to you because the month of
December is very tough in terms of
sobriety it's tough for a lot of people
many people you know they talk about
their family Christmas they like getting
[ __ ] up on their family Christmas but
to me it was always the office Christmas
party and you know when I was in
mortgages you would you would not only
go to your party but you would go to the
party - the real estate agents or the
title companies you would you would hit
a few different office parties you know
and even the bars and restaurants in
your area they all seemed festive and
when things seemed festive it seems like
a fun time and you should just booze it
up it just seems fun every day's a party
Thursday nights a party it's a party and
you can all just go out and and really
get [ __ ] up but you just can't do it
unless you're in the throes of it and
you're not ready to stop then just don't
drive get an uber get a cab because I
get it when you're ready to let it go
you let it go but there there is no
place that booze to me serves more of a
function than an office Christmas party
I know that obviously when you go out
Friday Saturday night you're trying to
get laid that's a huge thing guys and
girls heterosexual it's a big deal gay
dudes it's not as big of a deal most of
them are on drugs anyway I would imagine
I think most of them are not all of them
the dudes I hang out with her they're
barely gay they don't come out they're
very weird they're like they're not in
the gay scene so I don't really know but
most of the gay guys in the area that I
live in seem to be on crystal meth
I don't know if that's the case or not
but they also seem to have a lot of
money they seem to be doing well I don't
know is crystal meth a problem maybe not
I don't know the point is I know you
know people Rogan and Fitzsimmons talked
about it the other day it's like men and
women hitting on each other sober it's
weird but when you talk about social
interactions the office Christmas party
calls for getting [ __ ] up there's no
other time that calls for booze more
than that party because you kind of know
these people you spend your life
with them but you don't it's a very
interesting coworkers are very
interesting they're not your friends but
they are your friends you see them more
than your friends you see them more than
your family but there's that
understanding that if you will get fired
or if you quit it's over no office
friendships ever lasts it just doesn't
happen
don't DM me and tell me that yours did I
don't care you're a loser if that's the
case when you walk out of that office
it's kind of over you might see that
person a few months later you might have
a French onion soup but that's it
because your bond is being in the
trenches whatever those trenches are
whatever they are and then your bond
could grow into other things but it's
really contingent on where you work so
when you go out for that Christmas party
you know jokes hit so hard in an office
setting because everybody understands
the premise everybody knows Doreen
everybody knows she's full of [ __ ] so
when you crack on her everybody explodes
with laughter a really great comedy show
is the same thing it's like everybody
gets the premise they get what you're
doing and they get why you're saying it
that's why if your fans come out it's so
much it's so much better of a show
because they understand you that your
point of view when you attack a subject
they get it you have to do less work
bringing them in they're already there
you know and that's why some of the
hardest laughs I've ever gotten outside
of stand-up comedy have been in an
office and specifically at an office
Christmas party because that's the time
to bring out your a material everybody's
shit-faced
everybody knows the premise they
understand things are the government's
[ __ ] us we all gotta take this new
licensing exam to cut in our
Commission's the company's [ __ ] us
you know there's that moment in an
office Christmas party we are somebody
comes up to you and you don't really
know that person that well but you have
this interaction that you feel is really
meaningful and
you see them the next day at the office
and you realize that you hate that
person but it's that one magical moment
where you have a conversation about a
hockey game
you were both had and then the next day
at work you're like oh yeah I hate him
and he hates me and you can never not
hate each other because that's the way
it's supposed to be in the world but it
was that one beautiful moment at the
oven there's also that amazing little
huddle that you all have when you're all
smoking cigarette and by the way if you
don't smoke cigarettes at an office
Christmas party [ __ ] you I don't care if
you have emphysema and you have to smoke
it through a hole in your throat that is
a office Christmas party you smoke that
[ __ ] cigarette you do it nine months
pregnant you do it you do it however you
need to [ __ ] do it
don't [ __ ] when you go out and you
smoke cigarettes and you like usually
it's the boss and he's got a team of
guys you know four or five guys and beer
women whatever and it's you know he's
smoking a cigarette and he's just kind
of giving yeah you know it's like he's
giving you it's not really a pep talk
but it's just kind of a you know it's
like a year in review type of thing and
there's something nice about that
because he's like let me relate to you
as a human being I'm gonna you know I'm
gonna talk to you as a person and maybe
share some story from the past and you
know you're there and you're like all
this you know he at that moment what
he's trying to do is convince you that
he doesn't look at you like a piece of
[ __ ] which he does and he has no reason
not to but in that moment he's just
drunk enough and he realizes the
responsibility he has he has to like
look at you like a person and talk to
you like a person because he needs
people to work at the company and he
doesn't need you to go back to college
or [ __ ] you know move to [ __ ]
another country or whatever you're
considering
now or kill yourself he needs moved to
another country it's like who's my
audience end up moving to another
country but you know what I mean
move to another County maybe County I
meant County but I show that if somebody
says to me what do you miss like what do
you miss about drinking you know I kind
of miss an office Christmas party and I
and III that I'm reminded of that in
December I'm reminded of that in
December and I've been a really shitty
one I've been a bad ones I've been the
ones that where they bring in a hero
into the office cuz things are really
[ __ ] and it's been a bad year and they
bring in a big hero and some macaroni
salad and people just start making
drinks in the office it's I've been to
some bad ones
I've been and those are the worst
because people are not making that much
money they're pretty depressed and it's
it's very if you're in an office
Christmas party in your office you're
[ __ ]
I mean it's just it's not it's not a
good sign you gotta be at least
somewhere else you gotta be somewhere
else there's no other way there's no
other way that it works how many times
do I have to tell you people that you
need to change your life you need to get
new outlook you need to remove negative
toxic people from your life and also
positive people that's something nobody
tells you also have to get rid of
positive people to negative people is
that goes without saying but many
positive people also have to go that's
just a fact you also need to get rid of
material possessions that you once
considered useful okay and you need to
find sharper sleeker more cost-effective
alternatives one of them is the ridge
wallet
the Reid's wallet is a minimal front
pocket wallet that's designed to
streamline what you carry every day it
has 30,000 five-star reviews in his bed
way to carry your cash and cards it's
only it's a small wallet it's metallic
it is it is it's almost indestructible
it's you can the cards do not fall out
the cash does not fall out none of this
falls out what it is is a minimal sleek
wallet you use it you you streamline and
you take all of the [ __ ] that's in your
other wallet you look through you go
what do I really [ __ ] need you go
nothing I don't need anything I'm
throwing these cards out they're maxed
out I'm cutting them up I'm not gonna
live in a cycle of debt I'm not gonna
owe 21 trillion dollars to China and
have to finance it on a bubble of
illegal Wars and torture I won't do it
you throw those cards out you keep one
card one credit card one debit card you
get one business card your lawyer your
accountant somebody important that you
speak to okay you put a few other things
in there an identification it's all very
streamlined and simple everything else
is on your phone
everything else that you need is
digitized doesn't you don't need a big
wallet you doesn't it's unattractive it
makes you look like an idiot
makes you look like a fool it really
does
I think the ridge wallet is the first
step to making you reevaluate a lot of
the things in your life well how much
excess is in your life right now that
you don't need how many things and
people in your life do you not need
would you be better off without that you
could just get rid of dumped leave on
the side of the road do you need your
wife do you need your kids do you need
your pets do you need that job do you
need the state you live in do you need
your town do you need your mother and
father sister and brother do you need
your friends from college do you need
your high school buddy do you need all
of these things that weigh you down
these people these burdens these people
that expect things from you that tear
out a chunk of your flesh maybe you do
maybe you need some of them you don't
need all of them I know for a fact you
do not need all of them you can get by
with less you eat too much and you drink
too much you can get by with less you
can have your
and still survive you can have your
wallet and still survive you can have
your family and thrive [ __ ] thrive
you don't need these things I'm telling
you it's very important to re-evaluate
every now and then to look around at the
people around you and go why are they
here what am i doing starts with a
wallet while it is essential it's one of
the things you always carry on you you
get a sharp wallet you get something you
know it'll it'll start the revolution
you need a revolution of the soul and of
the Spirit you're bogged down
possessions it that's a Boomer thing the
hoarders floor-to-ceiling boxes poor
[ __ ] you don't need ok if you don't buy
the ridge wallet here's what I'll do I'm
gonna come to your house I'd kill your
family in front of you ok I'm gonna kill
your family in front of you if you don't
buy this [ __ ] wallet I'm gonna I'm
gonna find you I'm gonna hunt you down
and find you because it's a great
product and they sponsor the show and I
have one and I use it and I like it and
Ben has one and he uses it and he likes
it and I don't know what you people need
they got 30,000 5-star reviews what do
you need what are you waiting for we
provide you entertainment you want to go
back to watch it and [ __ ] Jimmy
Kimmel but or a Jimmy Fallon or any of
the Jimmy's of Seth Meyers it's not
gonna happen you're with us now
you run the pirate ship you have to help
you have to help fund the pirate ship
you know we're not the government we
can't sell weapons to Yemen we have to
sell Ridge wallets and that's what we're
doing ok yeah I'd love to be the federal
government just sell coke for years and
pretend well I don't know how it got
into the country I don't know I don't
know just sell a bunch of weapons to
Saudi Arabia a bunch of missiles and
jets I can't [ __ ] do that we're
slinging the ridge wallah it's a goddamn
good product nobody's getting killed
nobody's getting killed no crack babies
are being born through the ridge
you get what I'm saying I'm doing it
clean folks I'm doing it the right
[ __ ] way we've made a lot of blood
money in this country is what I'm saying
a lot of people just swimming pools of
blood money and they do backstroke in it
and then they get mad and they wonder
why people around the world aren't
really thrilled with us open a [ __ ]
book dummy this is one of the dumbest
countries ever when you go around and
you talk to people they know less about
anything than me than you'll ever any
human being you'll ever bump in it was
true and look at their wallets they suck
they're tattered pieces of old shoe
leather not Ridge wallet people Ridge
wallet people are smart sophisticated
urbane they get it they know they're
their warriors and champions Patriots
yes real Patriots not fake ones they
love America for the right reasons and
they want they want her to be at her
best all the time that's why they have a
ridge you know I'm very critical of
America but that's only because I like
America I want America to do the right
killing the right genocide the right
drug sales the right weapons
manufacturing okay I get that you got to
do a little killing but let's do it the
right way let's be cautious and careful
let's be neat ah by the wallet or I will
I will drive down your street in a car
and I will hit your kid on on his bike
and I'll kill him
telling you right now I'm gonna do that
if you don't get the wallet by the
wallet it's Christmas time it's Hanukkah
it's Kwanzaa it's winter solstice I
don't give a [ __ ] what you celebrate by
the goddamn wallet and give it to your
friend at work he'll like it tell him
about the podcast it's a great way
start a friendship you hand them a while
ago I listened his podcast they sell
those wallets
[ __ ] lunatic who screams and then
that your friend will listen to me
scream and in your car together you'll
you know you'll be in separate cars
eating your launch eating sandwiches
you'll just you'll have the windows
rolled up it's cold but you'll just hear
the screaming of me screaming and you'll
look at him and he'll look at you and
you'll give each other the thumbs up and
you'll keep eating your sandwich okay
Ridge wallet it's the way to go folks
that's all I'm saying
so here's what I want you to do it's
what I want everybody to do I want you
to go to Ridge comm /ti em use code TI
em for 10% off your order ridge comm /t
IM for 10% off your order do it or I'm
gonna make your life a living hell I'm
gonna start problems if you don't do it
please do it now I got to go do a set of
the Comedy Store and we'll finish this
podcast thank you goodbye
and we're back we're in we just got back
from the comedy store raining in LA when
it rains here there's no reason to be
here the city smells like [ __ ] not a lot
of people leave their home they don't go
out it's pretty bad the city's not
designed to handle any rain there's no I
guess what's the term irrigation or
flood system I mean it's whatever it's
bad it's bad it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] man
it's [ __ ] what are you gonna do go
down to Florida go down a sunny Florida
but yeah for all of you struggling with
sobriety issues over the holidays [ __ ]
and I hear you you know I get it I know
what it's like I I sobered up in 2010
and I haven't really had anything to
drink I haven't smoked any weed or
taking pills I haven't done any drugs
since then you know I mean it is really
[ __ ] amazing fat Oscar the
has jumped up he jumps up as soon as we
start podcasting he jumps up on the
equipment because he wants to do a
podcast but Apple will take it down like
he who wants to say things that can't be
said he's just a problem when I look
back though
I think December was my favorite month
to use drugs and alcohol since I was a
little kid since I started smoking weed
there was something so much fun about
walking around my town when the
Christmas lights were out and I was
smoking weed they're [ __ ] going at it
again is I'm trying to focus guys get
them out of here man they gotta go you
gotta go guys I'm trying to focus and
there's this little cat is [ __ ] Oscar
up Oscar's his big fat mess but it's
very interesting it's like MMA watching
them go at it and Oscar just has no his
reflexes are not good he's just a
[ __ ] mask man and he's really getting
his ass handed to him and he deserves it
which is why if it was up to me they'd
both be put to sleep which was what I've
told you to do with your pets earlier in
the episode if you remember but walking
around my town when I was 14 years old
smoking weed with my buddy all the
[ __ ] Christmas lights were out there
was something fun about it there was
something festive about it you know and
then I remember as I would get older and
then with somebody at a car you would go
drive around these really wealthy areas
in Long Island and [ __ ] all that
Christmas lights would be out it was
just a fun time to be [ __ ] up it just
is month of December just is you know
for other people was the summer I like
doing [ __ ] drugs in the summer too
don't get me wrong I'd like to interrupt
him a fall the spring the winter none of
that mattered but the month of December
to me was just a great month I love
doing drugs a month of December there
was something about it I remember you
know a lot of my you know what I could
look back at a lot of the times that I
remember with my friends getting [ __ ]
up they were around the holidays it was
Christmas break
it was parties it was as you get older
it was [ __ ] office parties and
[ __ ] going out to bars and everybody
you know there's something stupid about
Christmas lights that just make you feel
like your behavior is warranted there's
just something about hanging Christmas
lights on the outside of a house that
makes it okay that you're doing cocaine
in front of someone's children I don't
know what it is you just feel festive
you're just like I guess it doesn't
matter that we're doing cocaine with a
pregnant woman because she's got it Elf
on the Shelf you know I don't know what
it is but you know it's true you know
I'm not lying there's there's just
something about it that makes it feel
okay the worst food you can eat the
worst food ice cream and cupcakes and
cookies and hot chocolate
he's [ __ ] something about it's the
month of December you turn on the radio
and they said duh Mariah Carey song and
you know I don't wanna love [ __ ] I mean
and it's all okay like it doesn't matter
that I'm drinking you know 1,200
calories of caramel hot chocolate right
now
this is December I've earned this this
is the [ __ ] mud that Mariah Carey's
own by the way is is the official song
of every like fat you know curvy sorry
ladies body positivity time curvy Long
Island woman driving around like a mall
I know I love [ __ ] whispers and she's
just drinking a Starbucks - venti you
know [ __ ] you know cappuccino and
she's just driving home to her house you
know in Rosslyn you know that a parent
zone that's worth you know two point
four million dollars or in dad's the
shady Persian real estate dealings or
whatever in her you know her mom just
sits around and takes vicodin and you
know puts lipstick on reapplies lipstick
all the time and scratches herself but
so I know how tough it is out there so
if you're if you're [ __ ] getting
[ __ ] up in December enjoy it own it
but if you're not you know sober up and
realize it it's not a
good month it's actually not fun all of
this sucks it's not good the crowds the
people it's you know there there's
something to be said for it certainly
but you know on you know embrace the
hatred of it to sober up don't dull your
senses you know lean into how silly it
is and and you know this isn't the real
meaning of Christmas go it out and eat
and [ __ ] cupcakes and you know
getting you know buying a [ __ ] dildo
with Bitcoin for your sister-in-law the
real meaning of Christmas is [ __ ] you
know the real true meaning of Christmas
it's being [ __ ] rich really rich you
know that's the real meaning of
Christmas having a lot of [ __ ] money
having simple decorations a candle in
each window nothing gaudy stop with
those inflatable things on the lawn stop
it have a little class I'm gonna tell
you how to decorate for Christmas I know
many of you that listen to the show
literally are lost so here's what now
many of you don't own homes and you can
I decorate my apartment no this is to
the people that own or rent homes I'm
sorry if you have an apartment you don't
get to decorate it you don't get put a
little Christmas tree next to your
microwave you know listen I'm not
judging you I live into a crazy bitch's
house the point is this is for people
that have a home with multiple windows
or if you have a really nice apartment
and you know maybe you can also apply
this to your thing you know I'm not
talking if you own a condo I'm not
[ __ ] on you I'm just saying listen
you know if you live in a bomb shelter
it's gonna be a limited amount you can
do I've always been a fan of the the
single candle in each window because
it's Christmas but it's very creepy as
well and I like I Christmas should have
a creepiness to it that's not
overbearing like Halloween but you
should realize that it's you know it's
really another year it's the end of the
year it's the death of the year there's
a coldness to it and if there's a
severity to it you should embrace that I
really believe that's why the best
Christmas movie is what
and what is the best Christmas movie
let's see if you know it now Ben has
been raised you know he was raised in a
you know in in in it in a Texas rodeo
town and you know what is the best
Christmas movie based on what I just
said think about it don't fire off an
answer like you usually do because
you're always wrong the best Christmas
movie now again the season folks is
severe if there's a severity to the
Christmas season and this is what we're
losing it's not [ __ ] silly that's why
when you sober up you'll start to
realize that it is not just silly and I
want to bring back a severe Christmas
what is the best Christmas film A
Christmas Carol
not only is it not the best film but it
is such a basic [ __ ] answer that I want
to come over there and I want to
strangle you with the with the
microphone cord okay but you'd probably
get off on it because you're sick
repressed Texas [ __ ] you wouldn't know
what to do here's the point the best
Christmas movies It's a Wonderful Life
that is the classic [ __ ] movie it's a
wonderful [ __ ] life and if you
disagree with me right now
crash your [ __ ] car oh it's gremlin
no it's not it's not jingle all the way
it's not bad Santa it's it's a wonderful
[ __ ] life with a black eye plays an
angel isn't that true look that up and
that's nice that he does that because
it's [ __ ] you know everybody's
represented and the thing about it's a
wonderful life is there's a severity to
it it's about a guy and you know
everything sucks and he's on a bridge
and he wants to kill himself but an
angel tells him not to kill himself
Clarence Clarence right yeah he's not
black though he's he not a black guy
he's an old white guy the film is good
folks is my point I thought it was the
black angel the mixing up movies it's a
wonderful life is the best movie I also
like Scrooged but that's not the point
the point is this severity benzo he's
got to ruin everything
there's
it's a severe film it's a wonderful life
it's great so what here's here's what I
mean when I talk about decorations in
the day I like the Windham Hill
Christmas collection it's like a piano
music it's very somber there's a sadness
and a somberness I not a lot of peppy
Christmas carols do this become a somber
Christmas house I'm telling you it's
very important
the Windham Hill Christmas I'll find out
the exact one it's kind of piano it's
very somber sad but nice you reflect you
know you sit in your chair you go
remember what happened where's that guy
that guy's dead you know and then just
have a nice I thought uh you know candle
in every window ah nice Windham Hill
music in the house my mother when I was
young used to have these things that I
never really liked they were they you
know the the the the they were in the
window you would put these dolls in the
window is a big thing in Long Island
then they'd all have a candle and the
candle it was in their hand and they
would go left to right yes like back and
forth my mother would you know she
really loved decorating she because she
was insane but also because that was
what you know you did when you lived in
Long Island you had a house he would
make a display and my mother would put
these dolls in the window and it was a
big deal and I mean decorating was a
huge thing it took weeks my mom was
super into it I mean yeah I don't think
you have to do that I think you could
just put a single candle that you know
do it do a nice Christmas tree but very
tasteful tasteful and have it have it be
somber have it be somber nice wreath on
the door should look even if it isn't
expensive it should all look expensive
that's what Christ would want if he
existed which he probably didn't but it
doesn't matter we're we're a real
primitive race of people on this planet
and we're almost done which is why I'm
happy to be I'm happy to be at the end
because when you look around you go we
have we don't deserve to make it to the
next phase and we won't machines will
come in and they will they will take
over and we're ready for it and we need
it and I'm happy it's happening ok also
also what you could do is you do like
you know a little nothing but you
maybe a nice little ribbon or something
around you know do III you know
sometimes was 1950s lights are nice the
big colored bulbs I remember my mother
when I was a little kid I was in I was
in plays I was an actor when I was
little I started acting when I was like
six and the first guy that put me in
this play was a guy named Scott he was
director and he's dead now
and he had a winter wonderland in his in
the basement of his Long Island house
you know he was a gay guy I don't think
he ever told he live with his dad his
dad was like a real weird guy I don't
think he ever told his dad he was gay
but he did have a winter wonderland in
his basement so that might have given
the dads some idea that there was
something going on there was no wife but
there was a winter wonderland like
should the gut and Boy Wonder wonderland
I mean the guy would have like all these
dolls and all these like he was just a
big deal thing and I remember my mom
took me and my father there and we like
walk downstairs and this guy lived in
this house and his father was like a
psychopath his father was like one of
these Long Island guys and I think was
in a war and just stayed in the war
forever and had like combat helmets and
guns and knives all over his route he
was just waiting for the next war and
his son was downstairs you know with
like a winter wonderland [ __ ] display
in the basement it was very interesting
change from the first floor of the house
to the basement and me and my father and
my mother would like we went over this
guy's house we walked around downstairs
into this [ __ ] thing and my dad was
like what the [ __ ] is this I mean it was
crate was like the the level of detail
how meticulous it was it was one of the
first examples I had of somebody that
was so meticulous and detailed about you
know something they were just obsessed
with it and nobody would see it unless
they knew him like it wasn't in his
window or anything was the basement of
his house so he'd have to kind of bring
people in and when you walked in though
the living room was just like a regular
shitty Long Island house and then you
would have to walk downstairs and then
you would see this winter wonderland
display and it was wild I always think
about that sometimes
think about like what that guy was about
like what he was about just being living
in that house in Long Island having that
dad probably hated him or maybe liked
him no didn't like him but maybe it was
a maybe they got along I don't know you
never know
you know III don't I don't know well
what do I know but going downstairs
every night and just creating this world
this winter wonderland world in the
basement of this [ __ ] Long Island
house you know while your father's
upstairs loading his gun and preparing
for the next battle like what a like
what a wild country this is you know
what would a genuinely wild country this
is and that's why the whole thing where
everything is political now you just I
mean how do you politicize that how do
you make that in a Republicans and
Democrats and bigger small government
the truly fascinating [ __ ] in this
country is just how insane it all is you
know and and and and you can't distill
that to politics you can't you just
think about people's lives in the
proximity how close they live to each
other and these lives and these crazy
things you'll never know about people
you'll just never know what people are
into what their passions are what
excites them you know most people just
labor away at things they hate because
they have to it's just shitty you know
and you'll never know like what that
person wasn't like you'll never know
like you know they'd be like oh this
person loved the clarinet you know or
this guy likes he likes torture porn you
know that's his that's his thing he you
know and that's
you'll never know like what different
subcultures people really get into it's
like but it's just so crazy I always
think about that that to me like that
type of creepiness of Christmas not over
not Halloween scare boo God but it
almost a scarier Halloween but it's a
deeper I think about that guy in his
basement just make you know crafting
this little world
where he could just go down there and be
in this winter wonderland where all
these dolls had these candles and
everything and he would just go down
there and get away from his life and
spend time down there while his father
was upstairs just you know choking down
Salsbury steak or whatever and the the
darkness of that moment the idea of it
to me you know when I think about
Christmas I think about things like that
because he loved that winter wonderland
was like he invented this law and then
he just died I think he had an aneurysm
or something I forget he which is kind
of he just doesn't exist anymore that
guy but it's just an interesting it's an
interesting thing when you think about
this month it's a dark month let it be
dark don't have to fight that there's a
beauty to that there's something special
and interesting about that it's not
there is a lot of funny [ __ ] there's a
lot of funny movies and stuff but
there's a darkness to it that I don't
you it doesn't have to be silly you know
what I mean embrace what it really is
you don't have to get hammered and goofy
I mean you know unless you're young and
it's fun and whatever or you've earned
it or you think you know I mean but
there you can really just settle into
what it is which is the end of the year
it's the end of the cycle the cold comes
and the snow comes and everybody dies
you know and that's that's how I think
of it that's why I like that really
somber Christmas music you know it's
just it prepares you for you and then
January's just death that's my birthday
January 22nd I came into the world at
the height of death the coldness the
frost you know and then and then things
start to come alive again in the spring
but the winter is important so I always
think about that guy remember Scott
Scott he was the director and I mean not
of anything important I mean he you know
he directed plays at the local school
you know and uh
interesting man interesting stuff too
you know bean he had fun you know he had
a bit of fun life it wasn't a horrible
life he had friends and freaks that he
was you know the diff rends wid they'd
go out to diners after shows and you
know that was the that was my first
glimpse into what people's lives were
like when they were outside of the
mainstream you know people were out
because a lot of these people were you
know the that theater group they were
like they were [ __ ] uh what did they
do they were they were teachers and they
were some guy was a mailman some lady
worked at a bank like they had jobs they
weren't making any [ __ ] money but
then they would be in these shows and
they would go out you know to eat after
rehearsal or after the show and it was
like something for them to do and it
took them outside of their lives you
know and those our first glimpse out of
that I was six or seven I remember
internalizing that being like it's just
fun to go to a diner late at night cuz
that's like the ultimate [ __ ] you to the
world I remembered seven I was like oh
no one cares you go you go out late at
night you just say you know you said you
say what you want you laugh you don't
have to go to bed you don't have to get
up for school you know I did have to get
up for school but I was like these
people can just do what the [ __ ] they
want it was my first then when I got
older and I understood it I was like oh
that was your escape that wasn't their
life like that was their life that was
the part of life they liked to enjoy but
their their life is that Bank or that
[ __ ] you know job at FedEx or
whatever they were able to get out of
that and do these shows it was just
interesting looking back there was my
first glimpse of people that and none of
them really thought they were gonna make
it there was no idea that they were
going to get to the next level that they
were gonna support themselves many of
them were either well in the middle age
they just enjoyed it it was in the some
of these people were so [ __ ] talented
and and I've looked up some of them on
YouTube and they're still [ __ ]
talented and they're still doing [ __ ] in
Long Island just theater in Long Island
you know you know and I feel I feel
guilty kind of when I YouTube them you
know when I when I see what they're
doing because I'm I'm the most famous
person in the world now and I I wouldn't
if if any of them said hello to me I
would literally spin on them and then I
would have people that I walk around
with pull a gun on them
and and and and just know I just I feel
guilty because I was able to make money
doing something I liked and that's a
tough thing and and you know not
everyone gets to do that that's kind of
a cool thing to do I don't know how long
that'll last or you know if I'll end up
blow my brains out
probably both you know it'll probably
last awhile and I'll also probably end
up blowing my brains out but I'll get a
lot of people first don't you worry no
I'm kidding
but what I was just interesting that
whole that whole idea of that was the
that was the first glimpse I had it like
oh some people just you know they they
they they escaped and December feels
like we're we all feel like we escaped
we put lights on the houses we all
pretend to give a [ __ ] about each other
or we all you know talk to people we
haven't seen in forever we forced to
social interactions we go to the holiday
parties we lube it up with booze you
know it's just fun everything's
everything's supposed to matter a little
bit more and everything like that but
there's an underbelly there's another
side to it that's a bit more serious um
darker and that side you appreciate when
you sober up
when I saw if that excites you the idea
of just having a little bit of a cold or
Christmas this year you know there's
something nice about being sober and
sitting there in judgment of everyone
around you I'm telling you there's
something beautiful about that you send
me are looking at your family and
judging them looking at them and going
what the [ __ ] is what are they about
that's you know interesting and the
judge and yourself turn it inward turn
it right onto you but I do love this
month and I might I do miss it if I'm
honest with you I do miss you know you
know going to a holiday party getting
real [ __ ] boozed up and having a
forced conversation with someone there's
not there's no greater feeling than
going into something you think is gonna
sock it and having a lot of fun whether
it's a comedy show that you're doing
whether it's a date whether it's a
[ __ ] chance a challenging thing you
think this is gonna suck and then you go
oh this is [ __ ]
great and if it's a good holiday party
that's what it feels like you go in
you're like I'm just gonna get this over
with and then you know sometimes it just
becomes epic you know and then you [ __ ]
someone you shouldn't or whatever or you
know you know you just say something you
shouldn't you know and the booze is a
big part of that but you know if you
sober up you can always just go down to
your basement build that little winter
wonderland you can escape til you know 2
or 3 o'clock in the morning while
everybody is asleep you're like one of
Santa's elves working in your little
winter wonderland making a perfect
little Christmas village and then
upstairs you're your father snoring and
dreaming about Hitler you know I always
think about that it's a real it's a
wonderful Christmas it's a wonderful
Christmas memory you know it's really
that's what it's about guys let's talk
about sex good sex remember the days
when you were always ready to go now you
can increase your performance to get
that extra confidence in bed listen up
blue to calm that's blue like the color
blue blue true brings you the first
chewable with the same fda-approved
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
so you know they work you could take
them any time day or night even on a
full stomach and you always have a full
[ __ ] stomach because God forbid you
miss a meal intermittent fasting huh no
way
you love it cheese take as much as the
next person you have a diet that's high
in carbohydrates and refined sugar
that's why you can't get your dick hard
but you do what you got to do blue to
baby this is not just for guys who can't
perform it's for any guy he wants to
function to enhance their performance in
the bedroom it's not for [ __ ]
impotent guys it can't get hard this is
for the really tough guys dick pills are
for the cool people get it dummy
they're not for guys that can't perform
they're for guys you want to perform all
night long it's never enough therefore
people want to wear their partner's skin
they want to really [ __ ] just in and out
all night different positions beating
choking spitting coughing chasing each
other around the house involving food
weapons
choking [ __ ] pitch in a tent in the
backyard strangulation belts auto-erotic
asphyxiation BDSM waterboarding each
reported each other choke slamming each
other karate chopping I mean this is
what blue choose for it's not just for
guys look at their soft dick and their
like this what am I gonna do with this
sweet potato it's for [ __ ] tough guy
yeah
Navy SEALs I'm a big Navy SEAL
that's what's for Navy [ __ ] SEAL
blue-cheese prescribed online and
shipped straight to your door in a
discreet package so no one person doctor
visit no waiting in the pharmacy best of
all no more awkwardness they're made in
the USA and since blue troop repairs and
chips direct they're cheaper than a
pharmacy right now we've got a special
deal for our listeners visit blue to
calm and get your first order free when
using our promo code t I am pay $5
shipping that's it special deal visit
blue truth , get your first order free
when using our special promo code t IM
$5 shipping it's the better faster
cheaper choice and they really sponsor
the podcast if you really want to take
your performance to the next level
sexually or if you just want a hard dick
to work all day Chipotle whatever it is
blue Qi will take your performance to
the next level in every area of life
maybe you just want a hard [ __ ] to walk
around your insurance office at all stay
and feel confident doesn't matter
blue true is for you it's not only for
people that have sex some people just
want to see that baby nice and plump
blue shoe blue cheese comp remote Cote I
am just try it folks it is is you pay
five dollars shipping
get a free order first time t IM what do
you have to lose all you have to gain is
[ __ ] great sex what do you have to
lose nothing nothing it's private it's
discrete if you like the podcast just do
it order the Bluetooth don't [ __ ] around
order the blue chill if you don't like
it give it to someone as a gift for
Christmas give it to it well you can't
do that because it's prescribed don't do
that don't do that I didn't say that if
you're gonna like it
okay don't share medication you're gonna
like it you're gonna like it it's
[ __ ] blue chill the whole country
loves [ __ ] blue chill everybody in
this country is taking blue chill if
you're not taking blue chill you're out
of your [ __ ] mind because you need a
hard dick for what's coming you know
it's coming it's gonna be tough out
there you need a plump [ __ ] you need to
be virile you need to be able to have
children and those children need to be
able to defend the farm where you you
make your you grow your food because
Society will collapse within ten years
within ten years we'll have a massive
societal collapse so you need to start
raising your children now by they'll be
nine or ten they can work in the farm if
you [ __ ] right now good with the blue
Chu you can get a little army of
children that you will use to work the
farm and harvest the food that you will
eat they will defend the property you
know smart folks be smart that's not a
usual angle on a dick pill ahead there
you know have children and have them
defend you but that's the reality that's
where we're going with it because I
think that's necessary so think about it
when you go on a date with a woman tell
her be like listen I don't want to I
don't want to jump to conclusions but
I'd really like to have children
immediately so that we can raise them
and we can you know
count on them when you know when we go
off the grid because the grids gonna
collapse let her know let her know she's
with a guy that's woke real woke get out
of society woke you know that's of
course I'm doing character that's all if
society collapses you're not gonna save
yourself in the woods dummy it's just
you know she was gonna collapse and
she's gonna be a lot of pain for all of
us for a very long time and then
hopefully after enough I mean real
horror I mean just horror that you can't
even imagine
after that ecological catastrophe the
earth will kind of heal itself and the
new life will come but nothing you're
not better off by having a soft dick you
know what I mean during this whole thing
so blue ChiCom promo code Tim T I am
thank you but but you know this is a fun
month I do enjoy it and you've got some
exciting episodes on the podcast coming
up we have a lot of fun stuff the
patreon we had Kyle cashew Vaughn I set
a lot of fun things about him nice
things about him in the beginning of the
show we also have Sam Tripoli Sam
Tripoli's coming up next week we talked
about his channel get it taken off
YouTube he goes into some you know we
talked we talked a lot we talked a lot
about what his read is on Trump on the
you know what's going on with the deep
state with the dynamics of all these
Intel agencies and Trump we talked a lot
about that we talked we talked a little
bit not too much about Epstein but
Epstein comes up you know mean Sam we go
deeper I mean Epstein is like pop
conspiracy now it's in the news but me
and Sam go super deep so you know it's
an interesting episode I think if you
have an interest in that stuff you know
Sam lays out
what he believes he thinks is going on
and as always you never know but it's
you know he brings up some really
interesting possibilities
you know the peat rod is growing we
appreciate everybody that's subscribed
to it you know getting some extra
episodes we're gonna get some more
people on that patreon we've got some
big guests coming up in 2020 we're gonna
do video podcasts or coming back in 2020
but the reason that we're not doing them
in December is we're broadcasting from
our porch in LA it's gotten very cold we
can no longer do that so we're going
we're looking at a few different places
but we found a place we think we like
we're gonna start with the studio we're
gonna be doing the video podcast for the
YouTube channel that's all gonna be
happening in 2020 so don't complain
don't be upset it's all coming it's all
coming we have we have really cool [ __ ]
planned live stand-up shows happening
all over the place Tim Dylan comedy calm
tickets we have our life in the big city
shirt it's probably when this comes out
this will come out Sunday you don't have
a lot of time left to get it let me tell
you this is coming out you've got how
many days left Ben when this comes out
you'll have five days left to get the
shirt five days left to get the life in
the big city shirt and/or hoodie
you'll get it maybe before Christmas
maybe day or two after Christmas they
ship it on the 23rd will you give a [ __ ]
it's it's still Christmas until New
Year's and you know it you [ __ ] know
it between Christmas and New Year's
Christmas from the 25th till December
31st December 31st is another holiday
that's New Year's Eve New Year's Day
which my parents used to have a great
big party we had filet mignon my mother
made creamed spinach we had Peach Melba
dessert she'd buy a Sicilian Pete's on
Long Island the fat square one and cut
it up and then put toothpicks in it and
everyone would think it's like pizza
bites it was really great and we did
that for many many years and then of
course they decided they didn't love
each other and they dissolve their
marriage and as an affront to God but
New Year's Day is a great day for rest
and then you know
everybody starts starts working again so
you got five days from when this comes
out to buy the life in the big city
shirt
it comes from an episode of this podcast
where I said life in the big city and
that's something that my mother friend
Dennis said Dennis I was an interesting
guy he lived in my house he lived in a
van in our driveway for a while and he
still dispensed a lot of advice while
living in a van not that he didn't own
the van by the way he lived at my
mother's van but he still would give
advice that's a special kind of person
that while living in a van that he
doesn't own in the driveway of a house
he doesn't own still be able to give you
advice it's an interesting guy and no
matter what happened in his life no
matter how bad things got his kids
wouldn't talk to him his friend died
whatever he would just shrug and say
life in the big city and he would smoke
Marlboro Reds and he would drink wine
out of a Burger King cup and he would
just you know this was the greatest year
in the in the history of all years the
year was 1999 it was pre 9/11 where were
you in 99 Ben I was 7 years old in Big
Spring Texas Oh God God Big Spring Texas
Jesus Christ I was in Long Island New
York
I was I believe I was 13 and 14 I was
born in 85 to 85 to 95 95 99 I was about
14 years old and it was 1999 and my
mother was renting her house out Dennis
had one of the rooms and he would just
stare into the fire all day old love you
need work all that everything come home
he was staring to the fire smoked
Marlboro Reds he would say life in the
big city had a few different sayings
some of them are not appropriate to say
again these are not sayings that I
endorse I did not say them these are
things that Dennis said Dennis said a
lot Hugo there's an n-word in the
woodpile I don't know what that meant
that was a saying he had that is not
going on a shirt and then he would say
life in the big city good life in the
big city and he would just drink the
wine box wine out of a Burger King
and a lot of people like Oh where's the
burger can cup on the shirt shut the
[ __ ] up nobody's gonna know what that is
listen you have the box of wine and the
cigarettes he drank box wine it wasn't
always a Burger King Cup he could have a
cup from wherever it was just a plastic
cup it came from wherever it rarely said
Burger King on it you know Burger King
cups I don't think say Burger King those
plastic cops I forget that you know so
it was just a plastic cops sometimes it
came from Burger he came from wherever
he ended up getting his [ __ ] lunch
that day so it's a great shirt but he
would just say life in the big city and
I remember one of the best examples of
it was when his kids tried to reach out
to him after not speaking him for five
years he answered the phone drunk and
they never think they hung up on him and
they never call back and my mother said
your kids tried to call you but you were
you were drunk and and he just said life
in the big city
great is my life in the big city 11th
man you called my mother the bear she
was a big woman he would go the bear
because the Bears angry with me because
I got too drunk he goes I got too drunk
he goes to talk to my [ __ ] kids because
the bear is angry and he was just
smoking Marlboro red and I would just
sit down I would smoke a Marlboro red
next to him my friend Shea would be
there Shea would smoke a Marlboro red
and we'd eat baked clams and Dennis
would say the n-word and it's not you
know it's you know it's not like you
didn't really say it hatefully I'm not
defending him I you know he's uh he's a
character the shirt is not a endorsement
of his views even though he wasn't he
wasn't that racist you know I think I
think that's the way to say that he
wasn't that racist but that's the deal
get the merch enjoy it buy the products
that we advertise please if you need
them I mean if you don't need them you
can just buy them and give them to
people I mean you know but it's very
important
uh to us that you buy the product so
that we can you know I'd like to
advertise real big [ __ ] on the show I'd
love to Adeline I'd love to get a deal
with like Cilic side like Chile I'm like
why does Chile's let me just say like to
talk about the southwestern egg roll
wants an episode or [ __ ] talk about
you know you know I don't know I want a
big corporate sponsor ice cream salt &
straw or something like that you know I
use your product if you listen to this
Thank You of somebody reaching out to me
from the Saddle Peak lodge I'm gonna go
back there for brunch I'm sure it's a
good restaurant adjust Thanksgiving we
had a rough meal you know but I was
right it was that drunk that old drunk
woman got hammered you know they took
her out in a stretcher and then her
dirtbag family stayed and had the
Thanksgiving there so I will be going
back to the Saddle Peak Lodge and uh
that'll be that'll be a lot of fun if
you have a company that wants to
advertise on the show by the way if you
own a company that wants to advertise on
the show you can you could contact me DM
me through Instagram I do read a lot of
those messages I'd read all of them you
know I don't respond a lot of them
because some of them are insane and I
just sort of the time to respond
everyone if I don't respond to you on
Instagram don't take it personally it's
just because there's a lot of messages
you know sometimes alright thank you if
you say something I like sometimes I
won't I try to read them but I get a lot
of messages but you can contact me and
DM me through Instagram and if you have
a company you're interested in
advertising on the show you can contact
me we are gonna set up at you because
the Instagram system is not a great
system so what we're gonna do is we will
set up an email do we have an email for
the show know the Tim Dylan show at
gmail.com email forget Instagram forget
DMing me you could the end me you tell
me some other things you know you're
[ __ ] you know your mother's you know
has approved that Michelle Obama's a man
or something you know but email the tip
what is it the Tim Dylan show at
gmail.com email the Tim Dylan show
gmail.com if you want to advertise on
the show if you think that we're a good
fit for whatever your product or service
happens to be Tim Dylan show at
gmail.com contact us with with
we got a live podcast coming up in
Toronto in February which is interesting
I don't do a lot of live podcasts as a
solo podcast but we're gonna start maybe
doing some more in the new year and and
those are some housekeeping notes thank
everybody for listening really embraced
I just wanted to give everybody a
welcome to December episode and what
December means to me as somebody who's
sober December really means death that's
what it means but but a beautiful death
and then a rebirth and then into January
and which is also another death so it's
death a rebirth and then a death that's
kind of what it means but life but also
life you know if you if you like that
life whatever whatever listen to me
whatever gets you people to by the ridge
wallet do you understand if you want to
think December's about life didn't
[ __ ] do that is it about death do
that is Trump a demon from Hell maybe
is he a patriot a freedom fighter what
listen by the wallet don't [ __ ] with me
here I don't care what you believe
it doesn't matter we're all gonna be
dead they're all gonna do what they want
Washington shut the [ __ ] up log off
Facebook telling it [ __ ] Carroll to
shut the [ __ ] up or aunt whoever I like
my aunt Carol that's not about my mi
mine Carol's not that she's not the
device of one but the reality is do we
gonna do folks stop getting caught up in
these fake skirmishes and these wars
they don't matter
work on yourself like Gary Vaynerchuk
says build your [ __ ] business Gary
Vee what's he saying today let's end
with some Gary Vee quotes I want to get
pumped the [ __ ] up I don't know about
you guys but sometimes I wake up and I
don't feel like hustling and I don't
feel like grinding and I don't feel like
building a business and then III listen
or read the dailyvee and then I I'm back
do you know what I mean by that I'm back
because Gary Vee is the greatest
business
mind of our time because his company
sells ads on tik-tok that's business he
makes a lot of monies got a lot of money
what are some of the dailyvee quotes Ben
right now what's going well how can I
motivate the people let's see a lot of
this is just promotional I'm trying to
find a quote I mean he literally just
tweeted a heart emoji right 53 wheat
retweets 800 likes let's see I got a
find because he what are you saying with
the heart emoji guys is you gotta have
heart okay
nothing happens without a heart ask a
doctor you know it pumps the blood
throughout your body and your business
your body and your business okay don't
minimize that Ben that I'm you it
doesn't seem like that's hard work to
type heart but it is it's his strategy
what so what else what else is going on
kindness always prevails lean into
patience if you're confused kindness
always prevails lean into patience if
you're config what I here's what I like
about him he's not even trying to make
these coherent anymore like he's not
even trying to make them make sense
because he realizes that a lot of the
people he's playing to are so brain-dead
that it doesn't even have to like I'll
do some Garavito outs right we should do
a task where it's like is it a real Gary
Vee quota am i making it up but I think
here's what I would do if I were venting
care via quotes right I would say I
would say like that ones such a perfect
example of it because he's like lean
into patience if you're confused it's
like what the [ __ ] are you saying but I
would be like if I was a Gary Vee quote
I would be like I would some stupid
right
I'd be like empathy is consistency and
then people would be like yeah that's
right I think at least consistent
because you have to understand what
people going through all the time not
just once you got to know your product
you got to know your market empathy is
the first step to understanding your
market you're understanding people's
problems if you're not understanding
people's problems you can never
understand their solutions boom I'm a
guru right there I just did it now I'm a
guru you have to be on tik-tok you
should be spending three hours a day on
tick tock liking posts just trying to
understand what's going on you have to
understand the new media landscape okay
empathy is consistency consistency is
empathy lean into patience if you're
confused
the dailyvee that's it folks that's the
show go follow Gary Vee on Instagram
Twitter I'd love to do his show I would
love to do his podcast I think me and
Gary would have fun I do not hate him I
think that he serves a purpose I don't
know if the people that follow him serve
a purpose that would be my that would be
my question but I do think that Gary
serves a purpose I understand
to an extent what he does I just think
that some of it is wacky and some of it
you know as a comedian I have to call it
out because it's [ __ ] insane that's
that's what it is doesn't mean I hate
the person Megan McCain any of these
people that I make fun of IIIi
understand it is what it is like
nobody's you know nobody's perfect
though these are public people they get
everything they saying it's you know you
know people are but you wouldn't you be
hey when you say crazy [ __ ] all the time
you know it's funny and if it's funny I
have to point out that it's funny it's
funny when you tweet kindness is
delicious I it's funny it's funny when
you're you know David hog they all tweet
it's also general and vague David hogs
like the militarism of everything is
better
up so and what what's your what's your
[ __ ] idea David what's your [ __ ]
idea you just got a tweet racism's bad I
don't like regrown empower women it's
40,000 lines oh shut up shut up you
vapid [ __ ] you know be a real liberal go
to Gaza blow yourself up I respect those
people understand do you know how I
would show respect if I was sitting at a
table and somebody said to me my cousin
just she would say Ballmer I'd go [ __ ]
yeah I hope he's not here tonight but
[ __ ] yeah I go that's so interesting you
know how much do I relish that I want
that in LA instead of somebody call my
cousin works at Hulu do you know how
much more rather dumb somebody go yeah
my cousin's a suicide bomber oh yeah
he's you know straps of shoved a bomb to
himself and he blue you know I'm not
saying that the deaths of innocents are
good I'm not saying that I'm saying
that's an interpersonal aside bomb after
you've spent a lot of time talking to
people that work at Viacom someone who
works as a suicide bomber or is in that
line of work or is it terrorist or knows
terrace that's interesting it's like
what's that world like what's it like
maybe it's not better than working at
Hulu being a terrorist it probably has
downsides I don't know I'm not saying
that it's better to be a nicest and
working Hulu I think it is probably I
just think it's just more interesting is
what I'm saying I'm getting in all kinds
of trouble folks I think we gotta go we
gotta go like you know at a certain
point we cert we reach a certain point
in the program I'm trying to I'm trying
to make points but I'm making them
sloppily I'm making them slop you know
what I'm saying if you were out to
dinner with somebody and they said hey
my brothers who was a bomber or
something you know you you would just be
like it's the same dude if somebody's
about brothers a murderer he's a serial
killer my cousin's a serial kid you
would be interested that's what I'm
saying
will be interesting okay and I use Gaza
as an example it really could be
anywhere don't DM me and be like
actually the the seven-day war it's like
enough it's not my beef [ __ ] Irish
from Long Island you solve it you figure
it out that my [ __ ] beef my people
have been [ __ ] out forever
until they want to come to a country
like mine and make a [ __ ] movie about
knights and Dragons not even Game of
Thrones well I think they did shoot some
of Game of Thrones in Ireland today
probably don't look it up stop you
[ __ ] if you're such you're such a
sloth
Jamie Vernon is so good bringing things
up you're such a dumb Texas sloth you
can barely pull anything up everything
done does he makes it out to be so much
he's like it's so much work he's so much
work I just can't even dear I worked so
hard yeah you so much work
he's his fiancee Lurlene Lurleen Wallace
George Wallace's wife fans like did my
fiance learn lane and Lurleen zyban work
so hard he worked so hard being Lurleen
she knows we work hard too didn't Lord
our God knows how hard I work
he's a sloth they better keep it up
because I'll tell you right now we're
gonna get we're gonna get a team of very
small very efficient Asian Asians real
Asians Japanese Chinese high-end not
Filipinos not fat Asians although I do
respect them and identify with them
Filipinos are the only fat Asians
respect I respect the hell out of
Filipinos because of that you know it's
tough to be the only fat Asian and they
do it they pull it off kind of in a
stylish way all the Koreans are kind of
chunky too and they're also very fun
interesting
listen was SNL gonna gonna get mad at me
are you not gonna give me a jobs I
noticed that Filipinos arm
rotund than Japanese oh sorry sorry it's
the way it is you know folks
Tim Dylan comedy calm for live tickets
live shows god bless the queen god save
the queen
i'm trying to think of a real crazy
political I want to start like a
political party or I just wanted like
adopt the stance that is not
controversial because it's so stupid and
so I'll select I'm trying to think what
I could what I could really get behind
like what what what could I get behind
that's so crazy it like barely registers
as like as a political ideology should I
become a wig like a part like a
long-dead party go long dead political
party like me try to revive a long dead
political party I wanted to be in Dan
st. Germain lose a friend of mine we're
going to pitch a show where I ran for
Congress on Long Island or like a really
local job I ran a booth gonna like it
was gonna be like a unscripted show
where I ran and we had real advisers and
everything and we had debates and I ran
for like school board or something and
it was just this crazy campaign thing or
just kind of be funny as a show but TVs
dad movies of dad the irishman suck all
you have left is his [ __ ] podcast
listen to it by the ridge wallet don't
[ __ ] with me
goodbye